wealth is like seawater
the more we drink the thirstier we
become
and the same is true of fame
from the point of view of youth
life is an endless future
from the point of view of old age
it is a very short past
each person can be completely himself
only while he is alone
health so far outweighs all other
blessings of life
that a truly healthy beggar is happier
than a sick king
the clever are not so much looking for
loneliness
as they avoid the fuss created by fools
to get married means to have your rights
and double your responsibilities
nine tenths of our happiness depends on
health
it is better to find your mind in
silence
than in conversation
[Music]
he who does not like loneliness
does not like freedom
whoever violated trust once loses it
forever
living happily
means
living less unhappy
if we happen to hear how half a dozen
rams scornfully scold an outstanding
person
then we will understand that to value
the opinion of people highly
will be a lot of honor for them
[Music]
each person can be listened to
but not everyone is worth talking to
[Music]
we rarely think about what we have but
we always worry about what we don't have
societability of people is not based on
love for society
but on the fear of loneliness
politeness is to human nature what
warmth is to wax
compassion for animals is so closely
related to kindness of character
that it is safe to say that he who is
cruel to animals
cannot be a kind person
[Music]
people are like watch mechanisms
that start and run without knowing why
hundreds of objects that give people
pleasure
are boring for a big mind
a vain person should know that the good
opinion of others
which he so achieves
is much easier and more true to create
by silence
than by talkativeness
you should be very careful not to form a
very favorable opinion about a person at
first acquaintance
otherwise in most cases
you will have to be disappointed
we forfeit three-fourths of ourselves in
order to be like other people
he who writes carelessly confesses
thereby at the very outset
that he does not attach much importance
to his own thoughts
if you have reason to suspect that a
person is telling you a lie
look as though you believed every word
he said
this will give him courage to go on
he will become vehement in his
assertions
and in the end betray himself
fate shuffles the cards
and we play
intellect is invisible to the man who
has none
[Music]
he who has lost all hope
has also lost all fear
a fool chases pleasure
and finds disappointment
a sage only avoids grief
almost all of our sorrows spring out of
our relations
with other people
[Music]
don't tell your friend what your enemy
shouldn't know
the first 40 years of life
give us the text
the next 30 supply the commentary on it
such is the lot of great people in the
world
they are only recognized
when they are not alive
one day you will regret that you did not
hear these quotes earlier do not lose
the opportunity watch our next video
you